this report paints a tragic and
harrowing picture of repeated failures
in care over two decades
which led to unimaginable trauma for so
many people
rather than moments of joy and happiness
for these families their experience of
maternity care was one of tragedy and
distress
and the effects of these failures
were felt across families communities
and generations
the cases in this report
are stark
and deeply upsetting
of 12 cases where a mother had died
the report concludes that in three
quarters of those cases
the care could have been significantly
improved
it also examined 44 cases of hie
a brain injury caused by cancer by
oxygen deprivation
two-thirds of these cases featured
significant and major concerns in the
care provided to the mother
and
the report says from almost 500 cases of
stillbirth
one in four were found to have major
concerns in maternity care which if
managed appropriately
might or would have resulted in a
different outcome
when i met with donna ockerdon last week
she told me about basic oversights
at every level of patient care
including one case
where important clinical information
was kept on post-it notes
which were then swept into the bin by
cleaners
with tragic consequences for a newborn
baby
and her family
in addition
there were repeated cases where the
trust failed to undertake serious
incident investigations
and
where investigations did take place
they didn't follow the standards that
would have been expected
these persistent failings continued as
late as 2019
and multiple opportunities to address
them were ignored
including by the trust board who were
accountable for these services
reviews from external bodies failed to
identify the substandard care that was
taking place and some of the findings
gave false reassurances about maternity
services at the trust
the cqc only rated maternity services
inadequate for safety in 2018
which is unacceptable given the huge
deficiencies in care that are outlined
in this report
the report also highlights serious
issues with the culture within the trust
for instance two-thirds of staff were
surveyed and reported that they had
witnessed cases of bullying and some
staff members withdrew their cooperation
with the report within weeks of
publication
the first report already concluded i
quote
that there was a culture within the
trust to keep cesarean rates below
because they were perceived as the
essence of good maternity care end quote
and today's report adds that and i quote
again
many women thought any deviation from
normality meant a cesarean section was
needed and this was then denied to them
by the trust
mr speaker it is right that both the
royal college of obstetricians and
gynecologists and the royal college of
midwives have said recently that they
regret their campaign for so-called
normal births
it is vital that across maternity
services that we focus on safe and
personalized care where the voice of the
mother is heard throughout
the report shows a systemic failure to
listen to families affected
many of whom who had been doggedly
persistent in raising issues over
several years
one mother said
that she felt like a lone voice in the
wind
bereaved families told the report that
they were treated in a way that lacked
sensitivity and empathy and appallingly
in some cases
the trust blamed these mothers for the
trauma that they had been through
in the words of donna ockerdon
the trust
failed to investigate failed to learn
and failed to improve
we entrust the nhs with our care
often when we are at our most vulnerable
in return we expect the highest
standards
i've seen with my own family the
brilliant care the nhs maternity
services can offer
but when those standards are not met
we must act firmly
and the failures of care and compassion
that are set out in this report have
absolutely no place in the nhs
to all the families that have suffered
so greatly
i am sorry
the report clearly shows that you were
failed by a service that was there to
help you and your loved ones
to bring life into this world
we will make the changes that the report
says are needed at both a local and
national level
mr speaker i know that honourable
members
and those families who have suffered
would want reassurances that the
individuals who are responsible for
these serious and repeated failures will
be held to account
i'm sure that the house will understand
that it is not appropriate for me to
name individuals at this stage
however i'd like to reassure honourable
members that a number of people who were
working at the trust at the time of the
incident have been suspended or struck
off from the professional register and
members of senior management have also
been removed from their posts
there is also an active police
investigation
operation lincoln
which is looking at around
600 cases
given that this is a live investigation
i'm sure that honorable members will
recognize that i'm not able to comment
further on that
today's report recognizes that since the
initial report was published in 2020 we
have taken important steps to improve
maternity care this includes 95 million
pounds of maternity services across
england to boost the maternity workforce
to fund programs for training
development and leadership
the second report makes a series of
further recommendations
it contains 66 for the local trust
15 for the wider nhs and three for me as
secretary of state
the local trust
nhs england and the department of health
and social care will be accepting all 84
recommendations
earlier today i spoke to the chief
executive of the trust who was not in
the post during the time a period that
was examined by this report
i made it clear how seriously i take
this report and the failures that were
uncovered and i reinforced that the
recommendations must be acted on
promptly
but as the report identifies
there are wider lessons that must also
be learned
and it contains a series of actions that
should be considered by all trusts that
provide maternity services
i've asked nhs england to write to all
of these trusts instructing them to
assess themselves against these actions
and nhs england will be setting out a
renewed delivery plan that reflects
these recommendations
i'm also taking forward the specific
recommendations that donna ocadon has
asked me to put in place
the first is the need to further expand
the maternity workforce just a few days
ago the nhs announced a 127 million
pound funding boost for maternity
services across england this will
bolster the maternity workforce even
further and it will also fund programs
to strengthen leadership retention and
capital for neonatal maternity care
second we will take forward the
recommendation to create a working group
independent of the maternity
transformation program with joint
leadership from the royal college of
midwives and the royal college of
obstetricians and gynecologists
finally donna okadan said that she
endorses the proposals that i announced
in january to create a special health
authority to continue the maternity
investigation program that is currently
run by the healthcare safety
investigation branch
and again we will take her proposals
forward and the ss sha will start its
work from april next year
i would like to thank donna okadan and
her whole team
for the forensic and compassionate
approach that she has taken
throughout this distressing inquiry
this report has given a voice at last to
those families who were ignored and so
grievously wronged
and it provides a valuable blueprint for
safety and safe maternity care in this
country for years to come
finally mr speaker i would like to pay
tribute to the families
whose tireless advocacy was instrumental
to this review being set up in the first
place
i cannot imagine
how difficult it must have been for them
to come forward and to tell their
stories and this report is a testament
to the courage and the fortitude
that they have shown in the most
harrowing of circumstances
mr speaker
this report is a devastating account
of bedrooms that are empty
families that are bereft
and loved ones taken before their time
we will act swiftly
so that no families have to go through
the same pain in the future